when apple's current iphone sc was
released almost two full years ago we
were actually pretty impressed by
everything it packed in for the budget
399 dollar price especially the top of
the line 813 chip and for the past few
months we've been seeing rumors of
apple's upcoming next generation iphone
se3 with a brand new redesign finally
getting rid of the home button while
either adding face id or a new touch id
power button as well as a display size
around 5.8 inches kind of like the
iphone 11 pro and with that a full spec
upgrade across the board was expected
with 5g connectivity a new apple chip
and more and then on top of all of that
it was also likely that it would be
coming with apple's new mac safe
charging feature which i've really been
enjoying ever since the release of the
iphone 12. so i kind of imagined it like
an upgraded modern iphone 10r but with a
budget 399 dollar price tag which is
honestly a really good deal and very
competitive against the rest of the
android smartphone market however we've
been recently getting some very
disappointing leaks and rumors
concerning this new iphone se3 and if
they turn out to be true i have a pretty
good feeling that this will be the worst
iphone upgrade in apple's history and it
could very easily fail in the eyes of
consumers all around the world and if
you don't believe me i'll be explaining
my reasoning in this video so with that
said let me get into these leaks just so
you'll know how bad this situation can
potentially get earlier this month dylan
dkt finally came back and updated his
tweet from last year about the iphone
se3 but this time saying that the
awesome redesigned model that we were
waiting for has been pushed back until
2024
instead we'll be simply getting the same
iphone se designed from 2020 except now
with 5g and a spec bump yes that's right
literally the same design with the old
4.7 inch display with massive bezels and
a home button and apple plans to sell
this until 2024 that's four years of the
exact same design now you can see why i
think this is a problem because if you
look at any of the android competition
they're giving us modern smartphones for
around the same price for example we
have the google pixel 5a with 5g for
only 449 dollars and this device gets a
really good camera a 6.3 inch oled
display with a hole punch camera cut out
128 gigs of base storage instead of only
64 on the iphone se
an actual powered brick in the box which
you don't get with this phone and a
battery that's literally 2.5 times
bigger than the one inside the iphone se
and that's one of the problems i want to
discuss because if apple is using the
same exact design and chassis for the
new iphone se3 then the battery life is
still gonna be terrible like we saw in
mr who's the boss's recent battery life
drain test where the se only lasted
three hours and 38 minutes before
shutting down so if apple's going to be
adding 5g and a spec bump the battery
life will likely be even worse unless
they find a way to magically increase
the battery size within the same chassis
so paying 50 more for the pixel 5a with
5g to get a battery that's two and a
half times bigger is definitely worth it
along with all of the other advantages
and now if we take a look at samsung's
latest galaxy a52 5g it comes with a
4500 milliamp hour battery 128 gigs of
storage of course 5g and a 120 hertz
oled display for 400 right now that is
simply a way better phone for the price
so apple using the same old design until
2024
is just a bad choice in my opinion and
don't worry it's not just my opinion
because in my recent apple spring event
video some of our indian commenters let
me know that many indians aren't really
interested in this cheap old iphone
design they'd rather go for the iphone
11 or an android phone instead one
commenter also mentioned that since the
iphone sc is still not manufactured in
india they have to pay quite a bit more
because of import taxes so because of
that it's more worth it for them to just
buy an android phone instead or go for a
higher end but older iphone model which
they could probably find used and to me
this makes sense because an iphone se
with the same old boring design isn't
appealing at all i honestly don't care
much for this and it actually feels like
an embarrassment on apple's part
compared to a lot of the other android
phones in its price range but now
getting back to some of the new iphone
se3 leaks ross young recently confirmed
that the next sc model will still have a
4.7 inch lcd display and he is very
reliable since he currently has a 100
track record in terms of display leaks
and then a little bit later he also
mentioned that a launch in late april is
the most likely outcome for this new 4.7
inch se so if this new iphone se3 uses
the old design i don't think i'll be
recommending it to anyone over some of
the other android options or maybe even
the iphone 12 which should drop down in
price later this year and in my opinion
the worst part about the new iphone se3
will be that it won't support max save
charging which is one of my favorite
iphone features ever and it would suck
for someone to buy a new iphone and not
get to use max safe so because of how
boring this iphone will be i actually
think it makes sense for apple to
release the new se as a press release in
april instead of showing it off at an
event it's just not as interesting as
everything else out there and then with
all that said we've also been getting
some rumors that the se3 will be coming
with either the a14 bionic chip or the
a15 but in my opinion that much power is
overkill for the se because the display
will be sticking to the same 60 hertz
and you can't really do much on a
display that's this small so it won't
really be a great experience for gaming
or anything else with the power just
kind of going to waste the only benefit
of a new chip will be an improvement in
efficiency for hopefully a little bit
better battery life so all in all i just
don't think that it's enough for apple
to add 5g and upgraded specs to the
iphone sc because those things aren't
enough to make it compelling even at a
lower 399 dollar price especially if
they're gonna be selling it for the next
year or maybe even until 2024. so
because of that i'd have to say that if
this new sc3 truly does stick to the
same 4.7 inch design with a home button
and without mac safe then i honestly
believe that it's gonna fail even in
emerging markets like india so i really
wish apple just gave us the redesigned
model this year instead of waiting until
next year but of course apple is gonna
do what they're gonna do and maybe
they're intentionally making the se look
bad just to make the more expensive
iphones look good who knows but if you
think i'm totally wrong about everything
that i've said in this video please let
me know down in the comment section
below but if you enjoyed it then go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out one of those
two right over there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you